it's about time to get reckless in vegas
let loose everybody okay there's a new
show at the sahara theater that will
help you and michael shapiro of the band
reckless in vegas is here to tell us how
they can help you welcome
you look very nice thank you very much
very dapper is this is this something
that you would wear on stage absolutely
i like it homage to the rat pack i like
that okay yeah earlier in the show i
said rap hat meets green day but we'll
get to that we'll get to that in a
second just introduce us to the band
first and foremost tell us about you
guys we're a modern twist on vintage
vegas we want to pay homage to the
classic traditional vegas i love that
but we're rockers so how do we do both
and we figured it out we have a formula
that works really well okay so then tell
us what to expect in the show we're
seeing a picture of it right now uh you
you know you so we do some match ups you
can see uh here uh jimi hendrix manic
depression with sammy davis mr bojangles
okay we're led zeppelin told a lot of
love with nancy sinatra's boots are made
for walk and we have special guests that
we have for each month and it's it's a
it's a rocking good time dancers black
and white video montages wow background
singers so it's taking us back in time
but still
here present modern yeah it's our
interpretation of a modern experience of
the old rat pack days okay so for you
you started playing guitar at 13 you
know you played a little bit with bruce
springsteen at 16. so you you've come a
long way was vegas always a part of the
dream well i grew up in vegas so it was
and i moved away and then came back it's
just amazing that it's come full circle
and i get to actually be on the strip
headlining is an amazing experience
that's incredible so tell us you know
why should people come down who's come
who's invited to to be an audience with
you well anybody who loves great music
and wants an experience and also a
family show it is a family show it's
it's going to be 12 plus we're doing
five plus now but we're gonna uh
maybe make that a little bit older but
yeah it is a family show okay well in
that case i think it's time to get a
little taste of
reckless english
everybody loves somebody sometimes
everybody falls in love somehow
[Music]
or something in your kiss
just told me
my some time
is
we're caught in a trap
[Music]
i can't walk out
because i love you too much baby
love me tender
love me true all my dreams
[Music]
love you
and i always
and if there's nothing shaking come this
year
to lie i'm gonna it is july right it is
oh my god that was beautiful and like
you said it's reversal you give us a
little bit of everything hard to do in
60 seconds but we've got four oh my well
look i'm sold and i'm headed to sarah
for your show too for for our program as
well entertainment given to be giving
back giving back for every ticket sold
all right there you go kendall i'm gonna
send it to you now love it all right it
is time for today's pet